Okay, now that we've learned about arrays, let's look
at some other ways that queries can get inside of
documents in MongoDB. You know that our automobile collection
contains fields with some nested documents. For example, there's a
dimensions field that contains entries for weight, wheelbase, et
cetera. In MongoDB, we can query for values inside nested
documents. Using a dot notation syntax. Here's an example. Here
I've written a query that will retrieve all autos with
the weight greater than 5000. Now note that I'm
digging into the dimensions field using this dot notation
and accessing the weight field of this dimension sub-document.
So let's take a look at the results. And what
I'm going to do here, is just get a
count. Okay. Now these weights are in kilograms. So
for my fellow Americans, a kilogram is a little
more than two pounds. What we're going to do here is,
see what happens as we increase the weight here. Okay.
So we're done to about seven documents. Let's go ahead
and take a look at those. I'll just pretty print
this. Now note that one here is the Terex Titan. It
weighs more than 500,000 kilos. This one caught my eye
because, having two boys, we're all about the big dump trucks.
Okay, let's take a look at an example from a
different data set. Now this is one of my favorite features
of MongoDB. It's a powerful way to dig into your data and
really get a good idea for what it contains. As data scientists,
especially when we're thinking about data wrangling and data cleaning, this is
especially useful as you're auditing your data. We haven't talked about it yet,
but it's important to audit your data. After you get it into
the database, as well. So, looking forward to the next lesson where we'll
be using the Twitter data set, let's have a little preview here.
Now in order to do this, I need to access the Twitter collection
which is in the same example as database.
Okay, let's see what documents in this collection look like.
In particular, I want to draw your attention to this entity's
field for each Tweet and the hashtags field of this
entity's sub-document. Hashtags is where we've pulled out essentially any
hashtags that are used in this particular tweet. Okay, so
let's do a little mongoDB magic here. And, what I'm
going to do is set up a query where we are
also going to do a projection. And I'm going to do
all this using dot notation. Okay, so for our projection
here, what I want to do is pull out just the
hashtag itself. And, I'm going to make sure that that underscore
id field doesn't appear just so the results are a little
easier to read. And, here we go. So, we'll go
back in just a second and take a look at the
actual documents. But, what I did here with this query
was find all tweets where the hashtags value for the entities
sub-document was not equal to an empty array. Because the
way this data set is set up, if there are
no hashtags, the value is set to the empty array.
Then what I've done is I've said, all right, instead
of seeing the entire document for each document in the
result set, I want to see just the text value
for each of the hashtags. In a hashtags array. Okay
and note here that for those tweets that actually have multiple
hashtags in them, I'm going to get the text value
for all of those. Okay now, let's get rid of
the projection and see what this type of document looks
like as a whole. And now you can see that for
hashtags, we actually have an array. And so for every
hashtag that's mentioned will be enclosed as a sub-document like this.
With a field value for text and one for indices.
These being the character position, where this begins and ends in
the tweet. Okay? So what I've done with this query Is use dot notation, not just
to find documents of interest to me, but also to project out exactly what values
from those documents I want to see.
And one more time, that's accessing the entities
field, then the hashtags subfield and finally text
subfield for all documents in this hashtags array.